>> Yes, sure, role models are in my view very
very important. At this point and time, the
Middle East is trying to leap forward and
change it's position within the world structure.
It's trying to get more, more share, more
weight in the way the world is functioning
and that's its righful place between the community
of nations. But in order to do that, the Middle
East has to have enough leadership, has to
have enough resources. It does have enough
resources and financial capital, but the human
resources are what we need. From that perspective,
role models are very important, to inspire
the new coming youth. In the next 30/35 years,
we're going to have 150 million new people,
that's two Egypts. We are basically the youngest
population on earth in terms of the amount
of youth we have. So this youth is a true
blessing, but it could also be a curse. We
need to empower these youth by giving them
more tools, by giving them more role models.
So my answer is definitely yes, role models
are essential and important.